they're making moves
seems like everybody is
[Music]
I wanted to make a difference
I need to have a say in the future of
this place what you are asking is
unprecedented
I am unprecedented
you want that seat at the grown-up table
but it's not your turn Alex don't forget
to shut the door on your way out
Boop
three two one
we're off the air what's happening
someone's in the system get that music
turned off
uba has been the target of a Cyber
attack this hack is nuclear certain
things may come to light
did you ever tell anybody personal
things that were never meant to be
shared let all the secrets come out they
did not protect me they didn't protect
you
but I did
we are flirting with financial disaster
we need
we need to bring you a lifeline
take the money
how well do you know this guy what does
that mean do you know how much is at
stake here
this is a chance to create something
better but you have to really really
want it it's refreshing to get stabbed
in the stomach instead of the back so
thanks
Mickey Mouse
seems like everybody is
[Music]
what do you think Stone you want to run
this place
I know I made a huge mistake but I am
handling it fix it or I will you broke
every rule how do you sit
in that chair every night
time to smash Smash and shatter let's
burn it all down
we should finish what we started
foreign
[Music]